ich blicke naja sagen wir mal
fassungslos und auch ein bisschen
fasziniert auf die cdu den miserablen
zustand des eigentlich müsste sich die
cdu umbenennen in cee mu die christliche
masochistische union denn nur wer lust
am schmerz hat er trägt noch was diese
partei den menschen in deutschland und
vor allem ihren anhängern in diesen
tagen zumutet der eine der kandidat
armin laschet kann es nicht der andere
der es könnte markus söder darf wo das
soll es nicht und jetzt hat auch noch
eine frau aus dem team von armin laschet
karin green mehr oder weniger eine
wahlempfehlung für den politischen
gegner die spd abgegeben mehr
selbstauflösung war eigentlich nie und
das macht mir sorge weil ich fürchte
dass eine wichtige stimme der
bürgerlichen mitte immer leiser wird
oder vielleicht irgendwann ganz
verstummt das stimmt doch markus söder
oder
klar
ich will ehrlich sein das war nicht die
wirkliche frage auf die er da
geantwortet hat die hat dem heute
nämlich julian reichelt der bild
chefredakteur gestellt und da ist die
antwort noch vielsagender der nächste
bundeskanzler heißt armin laschet
klar
ein zögern ein gesichtsausdruck
ich würde sagen ein bild wie der zustand
der union in diesen tagen wolfern ja
also ich muss auch sagen das ist der
schlechteste wahlkampf sind von der
union je erlebt habe und ich habe schon
einige erlebt und auch einige schlechter
und schlechter auf statt
es gibt keine kampagnenfähigkeit der
partei die partei ist demoralisiert die
basis ist nicht zu mobilisieren
schwacher kandidat ich wüsste auch gar
kein slogan oder ein thema es kämpft
auch kaum einer in sofern wir können das
schnell darauf einigen das wird diesmal
nichts mit der union und offensichtlich
hat markus söder ja auch schon im blick
auf weitere zukunft wenn die union
verlieren sollte ist er denn natürliche
oppositions führer dieses landes und
kann in vier jahren da ist nix der
kanzlerkandidat antreten ich werde
trotzdem vorsichtig die cdu
abzuschreiben weil die cdu ist so ein
bisschen was wieder eichenschrank im
wohnzimmer der markt jetzt ein bisschen
blätter im modus aussehen aber er steht
einfach da so schnell verrückt du den
auch nicht und wir haben immer wieder
gesehen wie am ende doch die kernwähler
der union
aus irgendeinem grund in diesem fall
könnte es sein man will rot rot grün
verhindern dann doch ihr kreuz bei der
cdu machen das ist so ein bisschen wie
bei milch kaufmann geht es ins regal so
vielleicht könnte ich ja meine anderen
milch gekauft aber dann kauft man doch
immer wieder dieselbe und von diesem
effekt profitiert die cdu deswegen die
wahl aus sicht der union ist obwohl
viele schlecht läuft noch nicht verloren
ich glaube eher zäh mu da bin ich gar
nicht so weit weg ich glaube aber dass
ich wüsste er stehen für christlich müde
union also masochistische unterstelle
sie ja fast dass ihr freude daran haben
dass das unbedingt also wie man schnell
ich glaube wirklich ist auch nie heilen
freude wie man war ich selber so von
hinten in die knie treten kann wie man
offen abweichen kann vom eigenen
kandidaten wie man zu erkennen geben
können durch so eine politik des augen
rollen von fast allen also wie alle
wichtigen cdu politiker haben jetzt
langsam schon so darf er hat der armin
also so wird das ist das ist für mich
schon fast lust am untergang ich glaube
sie sind müde geworden sie sind auch
müde geworden zu kämpfen sie sind auch
in das land wenn ich konnte man jetzt
diese woche noch mal so als wir den
bundestag verfolgt haben wo jeder seine
chance genutzt hat um ja gesagt hat das
ist jetzt die grosse bühne jetzt muss
ich angreifen und ich sah armin laschet
der sich da verzettelte und frau berbalk
noch antwortete und noch eine schleife
drehte und noch eine schleife treten am
ende fragt man sich moment mal spricht
der mann jetzt eigentlich noch zu den
wählerinnen und wählern oder versuchte
irgendwie den anderen parteien oder am
ende aus seiner eigenen partei klar zu
machen so ich habe sachlich wirklich
ahnung von dem was ich hier mache und
das wirkt er tatsächlich müde aber eben
auch ein bisschen verzweifelt
aber die müdigkeit ich glaube die es
auch gegeben nach 16 jahren an der
regierung das mit 16 jahren angela
merkel so einschläfernd das mit einem
gerade gar nichts anderes übrig bleibt
deswegen ärger aber auch die die ganze
das ganze führungspersonal auf
bundesebene ist ja fast seit 16 jahren
mit dabei und seit 16 jahren haben die
regierungsverantwortung die meisten
kennen ja gar keine andere rolle als
regierungsfraktion zu sein und ich
glaube da ist auch wenn ich das
bewusstsein da das ist in den nächsten
vier jahren anders sein könnte das mal
nicht mitregiert und das dürfte so ein
bisschen zu dieser einschläferung führen
und ich meine mit dem parteivorsitzenden
der jetzt gewählt worden ist hat sich ja
auch die die haben sich die delegierten
ja auch ganz bewusst eigentlich für den
kandidaten entschieden der merkel am
ähnlichsten ist insofern geht dann so
ein bisschen weiter ich glaube sie haben
sich für den entschieden von dem sie
gedacht haben der macht es weiter und
weiter war aber auch gedacht bei 35
prozent oder bei 32 prozent das hat er
aber jetzt ja offensichtlich nicht mehr
im kreuz des zu schaffen ich finde das
ganz gut dass die jetzt in die
opposition gehen werden
aber ich muss auch sagen dass ich glaube
diese wahl wird in der letzten woche
entschieden an oder kann vielleicht kann
also opposition ich will es mal kurz zu
besetzen sie glauben es wird entweder
rot rot grün oder einer ampel also
jedenfalls schwarz frei naja ich weiß
rot rot grün wird es nicht werden und
rot grün das find ich hab mal so
interessant wird ja immer so behandeln
als würde das programm der linken
genommen und 100 prozent umgesetzt in
dieser koalition
aber die haben ja auch keine köpfe das
ist ja leider auch das ist ja peinlich
da warst angeboten wird und das ist
letztendlich ist es der denkzettel es
ist zeit für denkzettel und
letztendlich glaube ich bei der cdu ist
es so die brauchen halt eigentlich mein
ersatz für merkel und den haben wir halt
noch nicht und söder sich
irgendwie nicht als kanzler ja wobei er
immer nur bayern redet jeden zweiten tag
mit bayern hier in bayern
aber wenn man sagt es wird zeit für
einen wechsel und 16 jahre jetzt muss
man sich hier kriegen möglicherweise
olaf scholz als katze die spd regiert
von den letzten 25 jahren 21 übrigens
mehr als die cdu und nicht selten mit
olaf scholz und es ist doch nicht so
dass wir jetzt eine woge der
begeisterung im land hätten und es
stehen
die fan gruppen an den straßenrändern
machen die ola welle für urlaub das ist
überhaupt nicht der
fall und auch die spd es hat keiner
zeile keine wahlkreis rache hat kein
thema wo man sagen wir das zieht jetzt
wirklich die bevölkerung die werte für
die spd sind nur so weil die anderen im
moment noch miserabel drin war das
peinlich einer ganzen aber da möchte ich
an etwas erinnern wir kritisieren alle
armin laschet und ich finde für die
wahlkampfführung mit guten argumenten
habe der mann hat in seinem leben nun
schon in serie bewiesen deshalb verloren
geglaubte waren in letzter minute dreht
ihr habt bei hannelore kraft bei seiner
wahl als ministerpräsident war der 14
tage
er ist nicht im amt da hat er dann hat
der friedrich merz wir uns an die
umfragen er lag abgeschlagen hinten
keiner hat geglaubt dass der armin
laschet ihn besiegt dann hat dein
letzter minute besiegt dann kommt das
duell mit söder die ganze nation die
partei hat söder gerufen sein das ist
doch der bessere kandidat und es schien
auch so das würde am ende an dem morgen
starten wir alle nicht schlechter kommt
der armin und hat gewonnen ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass so eine ähnliche
mechaniker und 20 der september dass die
schwarze säulen
ich hoffe es reicht ja 25,1 prozent aus
heutiger sicht werde das intern gerne
wäre ich gerne auf den letzten und dann
wird er vielleicht mit einem kleinen
vorsprung doch bundeskanzler machte
jamaika-regierung also ich denke wir
sind in diesem jahr wirklich häufig
überrascht waren über den über das war
ja und wir könnten sich auf der
zielgeraden auch gar nicht das spannende
an der an der sache die sich ja macht
aber viel spaß dem dem wahlkampf zu
folgen aber die frage wäre jetzt bei der
bei der kür zum parteivorsitzenden war
es ja in der tat seine rede die er
gehalten hat die auf den letzten metern
was bewegt hat welche gelegenheit hat er
denn jetzt aus ihrer sicht auf den auf
den letzten metern das ruder rumzureißen
also ich finde der wahlkampf ist für für
solche momente
ich erwarte ja gar nicht mich geglaubt
das momentum wird kommen durch die angst
vor rot rot grün weil das etwas ist die
viele leute auch aus der mitte sagen
kommen eine ampel regierung werde
schlecht aber rot-rot-grün das will die
mehrheit der bevölkerung auf keinen fall
vor allen dingen nicht die kernwähler
der union und die waren bisher so
demoralisiert der sonne ich werde nicht
mehr aber wenn du jetzt daran denken
dass da ein bad und einem kipping und
eine eine wissler auf einmal dieses land
regieren dann sollte den weg kommt dann
greife ich doch wieder zu meiner guten
milch und will dies auch den einbau
scheint sich noch sagen der
eichenschrank ist sozusagen die
wahlkampf also der druck der jetzt
kommen muss glaube ich nicht dass er mit
einer warnung vor rot rot grün diese
alte rote socken kampagne
artikel ja sozusagen schon da muss
eigentlich irgendwas aktives nach vorn
kommen sonst ist es wahrscheinlich
wirklich nicht mehr zu gucken und 1
vielleicht noch zu urlaub scholz ich
glaube dass die leute das gefühl haben
also rot rot grün macht der nicht der
hat es geschafft er zu verkörpern dass
das für ihn auf keinen fall in frage
kommt ohne es ganz deutlich zu sagen das
muss man erstmal schaffen das ist
übrigens ein tolles kompliment für eine
wahlkampfführung etwas zu verschweigen
was man sagen müsste aber alle glauben
das macht er auf gar keine höher und ich
glaube wege hier macht es auch nicht
mehr brauchte das als drohung er
persönlich nicht aber hinter ihm stehen
und sich kevin kühnert und ersten und
bojan und
koalitionsverhandlung werden von der
parteispitze geführt ja das stimmt aber
gern
koalition ist es nicht so ich glaube
nicht dass ich will dich mit den linken
dann leben will ich lieber die cdu da
wäre ich war ein ganz ganz vorsichtig
also ich glaube nicht dass es unbedingt
passieren muss hat sich nicht festgelegt
er kann es trotzdem noch zu
transportieren ja mach ich
wahrscheinlich nicht aber es würde die
menschen nicht mal glaube ich so
wahnsinnig abschrecken nein ich glaube
er ist wird sein argument in die aus
spd-sicht ungeliebte ampel zu kommen er
wird sagen er wird sagen also wird das
machen wir nicht und lindner wird sagen
ich bewahre deutschland vor diesem links
furchtbaren linksrutsch und plötzlich
ungefähr so am 28 september an sich über
alle in den armen liegen und werden
sagen ja genau also olaf scholz als
kanzler christian lindner was wird der
finanzminister landes müssen
christian lindner der finanzminister und
wird dann grüner außenminister lawrow
werburg die haben sich bewerbungen außen
stand die völkerrecht
haben wir doch schon die regierung
schuldig wurde olaf
roten grün-rot machen aber ich glaube
die gedanken muss er sich auch gar nicht
mehr groß macht und selbst 29 zu 15 da
ist soviel hoffnung prämierten
weine ich denke in wechseln ich glaube
an sehen das aber das finde ich auch das
faszinierende das eigentlich so viele
den wechsel wollen ja dass wir die
deutschen aber ausgerechnet die grünen
eigentlich die einzigen die den wechsel
wirklicher bei führen können gerade bei
52 die deutschen wollen eigentlich die
ansicht dass ein denn die meisten sind
halt nicht die die sie zu diesen nicht
halten die wollen wechseln und weil da
ich weiß diese also gibt es
einschränkungen ein das ist der beiden
bilder duell ja und er sagt nein es gibt
keine einschränkungen geben
und und habe gesagt dann na ja es wird
einschränkungen aber ohne dass ich es
mitbekommen aber
[Musik]